[Music]
droid you ten minutes I just gotta put
on their clothes you could have like the
body of a man now
hey I cannot be weird okay keep close
men do it yeah you close the door yeah
going off to find your college let's
make this special we're fully booked
tonight how did that one that's not
available
Oh looks like it's available yeah it's
not at night my mind drifted back to
college so many friends have become
successful
Craig Fisher worked for the White House
Jason Hatfield had his own hedge fund oh
really worse there sold his tech
companies 40 what do I have I work for a
non-profit ain't nothing to show for it
somebody asked about you you know
whatever helps you these are the
competitive schools Troy just try not to
put too much pressure on yourself I
found so I think spoken to pretty much
everywhere I apply the kids going to
Harvard don't jinx me did my son is a
very talented musician also composes is
some music so wonderful I'm pretty sure
Harvard is gonna be in the running you
think Harper's got a chance suddenly my
thoughts darkened Troy could easily end
up struggling with me this is Harvard
even geniuses get rejected we need to do
everything we can
I'm about to go up my interview do you
really need to be jumping all over me
right now you're nuts
there's no sound jaded I started out as
idealistic as any of your friends over
there you're 50 years old and you still
think that the world was made for you
I'm 47 sometimes I worry that people
think of me as a failure oh that's right
you have your little thing oh that is a
cool thing that you do that is good
stuff your friends I'm like Dix
anybody's thing about themselves
the only person that's thinking about
you is me
like crazy how we made this kid it's
this brilliant amazing person proud of
you
daddio some kind of nervous breakdown
[Music]
you